on va partir immédiatement pour la
tunisie avec toute l'équipe pour un
périple exceptionnel il y a quinze
valises
il y en a neuf qui partent et si ce qui
reste pour l'instant
caroline ithurbide isabelle morini-bosc
maxime guen jean michel maire francesca
antonetti gilles verdez et qu'elle iv
novelli parts
il ne reste plus que deux tickets un
ceux qui ne partent pas ce qu'ils ont
perdu
daniel moreau ludivine retory benjamin
castaldi mokhtar c'est un enfant du pays
un enfant de la tunisie tu avais la
valise numéro 10 le disent c'est la
balise que tout le monde voulait tuer
aller chercher la valise numéro 14
ce qu'on va perdre un deuxième poids
lourd après benjamin castaldi mokhtar ta
valise
pèse 9 kg de sens yonne
[Applaudissements]
m
reste aux quatre valises
c'est une catastrophe et sherritt une
catastrophe il reste quatre valises et
leurs dates une gagnante
il reste il reste delphine wespiser il
reste match de leurs maux il reste
christine kelly et lil reste doc gynéco
ou une place il ya donc une place pour
quatre et en plus j'aime toutes ces
personnes j'aimerais vraiment qu'ils
viennent bah oui on va passer donc
maintenant à la valise numéro 10 la
valise de mathieu delambre jeunes 25 %
de chance vous avez donc 25% que mathieu
est ce que vous gardez la valise numéro
10 où est-ce que vous la donner je vais
prendre la 14e à partir pour cette
victoire allait mathieu alors ces 10 11
12 12 ou 15 bien je vais prendre
quelques est partante laquelle c'est la
rose
gfr mathieu c'est moi
est ce que vous êtes sûr que vous prenez
la 11
j'ai du sang tunisien dans ce sens me
réchauffe au moment où je vous parle
très petit il me dit quelque chose et il
me dit 11 voir à droite mathieu healy
22h51 ouais je vais aller chercher la
valise numéro 11 s'annonce déjà aux
confrères et consoeurs offert tu peux
rentrer chez eux passeront alors week
end à saint mathieu oui vous pose la
question une dernière fois
ouais ne reste plus qu'une valise
gagnant ouais ce que vous êtes sûr de
prendre la 11e oui c'est à dire celle de
christine kesha de christine la merde
c'est la tienne
oui oui de christine kelly qu'on aime
énormément il ya plus de évidemment là
allez je vous garde et l'a10 où est ce
que vous prenez l'a 15 où est ce que
vous prenez la 12 l'argent pour je garde
la 11 ans à dieu avait l'a10 à prendre
je viens de vous dire la 11e' l'entend
pas et portugaises ensablées
ok on voulait la ronce bref sort en est
jeté
alea jacta est
quelques minutes le pays me diras
choukrane beaucoup l'accusent la presse
ne parle pas de la noce à tous mes
frères que j'arrive bientôt et de
brouillard oui aux battues oui ou non
mais oui mais oui la question des
derniers ouais ce que vous gardez la
valise numéro ce que voulait que jamais
toscane un scan de telos cannes
soudain il a pesé mais entre d'armes
lors de mon deuxième prénom
allez-y excusez moi ça parce qu'il ya
dans votre valise ta vraie scan
d'ailleurs en quoi ces prothèses
mammaires n'ont pas grand débat nombre
d'hélium sahel vous êtes très doux alors
du secteur on dirait des testicules
grâce à lui on est les stic de deux
valises me plaît à les voitures allez
vas tu la regardes garde mais j'ai pas
comme mokhtar ou comme gilles je suis un
leader donc un décideur a donc il va
changer je cotise à perdre donc je garde
la 11
ce n'est pas votre bave à l'isr oui mais
c'est que j'ai choisi à tarder à me
faire ch essuie là sa phrase un regard
de la rose est bien à côté de toi pour
la voir non merci
c'est ce qui tend nuit est ce que je
peux vous voyez vous monsieur qu'est ce
qui vous ennuie sais que si je viens à
moi j'ai envie que vous veniez oui oui
mais je voulais vous savez très bien que
si je viens y aura deux stars là bas
quelqu'un peut rivaliser
oui connard là bas c'est sûr j'arrive
là-bas si je peux vous dire c'est justin
bieber est plutôt justin berbère si vous
avez bien votre passeport déjà du tout
c'est mon lexique du tunisien ce que
vous avez votre passeport ou pas sans
rigoler à ce que vous avez vraiment
passeport oui mais je n'ai pas besoin
d'un bal où nous sommes c'est vrai comme
ça arrive
mathieu allez on arrête de rigoler je me
posais votre valise cher la perspective
si je respecte la tunisie craint que
c'est d'être sûr et certain vécu comme
pour kelly comme pour ludivine ouais
comme pour mokhtar je vous laisse et 5
secondes
est-ce que vous gardez la rose ou est-ce
que vous la changer
c'est bon ça
kroll à l'âge c'est parce qu'on s'est
parlé avec ma voix intérieure ouaddou
laquelle celle qui dit plein de
conneries mais les calages pascal d'une
tunisie quoi cyril oui le bulgare garbia
range garde change garde les cils de
faire ce qu'il veut reste une seule
gagnante juin je garde la 11 à matthieu
delormeau
oui enfin kader keita packager match
soit pas jaloux que que j'aime la
tunisie
franchement regardez moi tout est là bas
qu'à sa tête et là bas que je parte
là-bas c'est que la bande même allée
bacchus est la 11e je n'ai vu qu'un soir
mathieu n'ont pas vocation meego back to
my plein je vais te taper mathieu votre
valise est ce que si cette balise est
gagnant ouais ouais c'est mort pour les
gîtes sont perdantes redire que delphine
christine et doc ne partirons pas
en gros chien gros plan sur moi
vous vous lèverez mathieu il est vrai
sorry bbc je tends prise par mon ami
alors d'autres de caste des jeunes
[Rires]
[Musique]
mathieu votre valise il fait 7 kg 1 860
et plus t'es quoi si elle fait plus de
10 kilos en moins de 10 kilos c'est
exactement le dit qu elle pas celle fait
plus de 10 kg ha ne part pas
malheureusement mathieu peut-on show
nous ayons vraiment envie de venir ou
pas et touche au pied de la vérité a
vraiment envie de venir ou pas annonce
des alouettes ce que vous avez vraiment
envie de venir le web annonce déjà le
wap ce que vous avez vraiment valoir les
poi poi a les mêmes mois à vous avez
vraiment envie de venir
je suis fatigué c'est sûr que c'est un
peu comme daniel vous avez envie d'aller
vous prouver vous propose en tunisie où
avec daniel mais avec daniel sera pas du
rock
mathieu malheureusement vos routes on se
sépare et ce que daniel a perdu et que
vous votre valise fait 9 kg
matthieu delormeau
regardez battu e mc2 avoir appris la
dernière valises y attendent
[Applaudissements]
y compris les chéris on a donc l'équipe
pour la tunisie
matthieu delormeau c'est quoi vous êtes
satisfait franchement ils auraient
j'aime tout le monde mais c'est vrai que
voilà delphine j'aurais adoré qu'il
vienne même d'hakim postino sinon bah
oui si la base est bon aussi mais les
chéris non je donnerais l'on partira
pendant tout le monde partira pas vous
le voyez on est neuf à partir et en vrai
on a dit place d'un docu une
je vais demander à mes dix de m'amener
la valise diplomatique
vous nous enlever pas carrément cette
valise diplomatique permet à huy la
golden à une personne que j'aurai choisi
de partir
quoi qu'il arrive elle est
malheureusement la personne qui partir
avec sa valise devra s'habiller avec les
affaires ne partira qu'avec cette valise
elle n'aura pas sa valise cette valise
je vais la donner à perdre on espère
n'en aura que deux solutions ou il me
dit non j'ai perdu je ne pars pas
ouais se perdant me dit je prends la
place de quelqu'un on joue bien ce cruel
dans l'autre on verra les vrais sa soeur
de votre tête tout ça c'est sûr ça ne
sort pas de mon slip
[Rires]
ohlala cette valise c'est vous encore
qu'elle ait décidé enfin quelle idée
vous avez vu je vous ai écoutés sur doc
gynéco je vais vous écouter encore sur
cette valise quand on fait pas venir une
vallée pour savoir à qui donner cette
valise offert mais pas votre gueule
cette valise je vous dis delphine j'te
kiffe ludivine j'te kiffe christine
aussi daniel aussi mais cette valise tu
la donnes à mon ami elle serait bien la
donne à mon ami benjamin comprenez bien
sûr c'est will et tous les jours à mes
côtés c'est mon pote c'est mon frère où
benjamin je vais te donner cette valise
et aura le droit de me dire cyril non
j'ai perdu
donc je ne pars pas et je laisse les
autres partir ou bien tu pourras me dire
oui cyril je pars mais à la place de
quelqu'un et ce sera le dernier switch
de la soirée je vous le dis les autres
ne partiront pas et après il va se
passer quelque chose de fou
en belgique
je te donne cette valise ce soir c'est
la soirée des décisions pour toi je te
la donne cette valise c'est une grosse
décision je te laisse un petit peu de
temps mon benji sais où tu me dis oui je
pars ou à la place de caroline ou à la
place d'isabelle ou à la place de maxime
ou à la place de jean michel aulas place
de francesca ou à la place de gilles ou
à la place de qui nous voit la passe de
mokhtar ou à la place de mathieu ou à la
place de toc ou bien non j'ai perdu
et bien c'est comme ça c'est horrible
ouais je sais assez près trading
d'accepter sa défaite comment je sois
très digne texte d'abord il donnera la
raison et après le nombre d'armes quelle
horreur
oui la vie est cruelle
reste qu'apple soit que non on n a
jamais on est très bien je peux pas pour
la peau de quelqu'un m'a jamais un
banshee je me vois moi je peux pas t sur
bbc je peux je vais pas tarder à tomber
par mon chéri tu dis on est une famille
je peux jamais nous a fait son père ne
peut pas qu'on l'appelle de quelqu'un ça
me ressemble pas c'est pas possible je
sais que ça ne ressemble pas à l'homme
que je peux alors ça va bientôt dans mon
sac chat on laissait non mais je suis je
ce n'est pas moi que de prendre la place
de quelqu'un sur ce plateau voilà je
vous le dise snc n'est pas transformée
passant le pas
bravo bah oui je suis père m'a jamais
donc pas à vous décider de ne pas partir
c'est tout à votre honneur m
benjamin donc ne peut pas le peuple vous
ne partirez pas à moins que l'homme est
une personne
qui part déjà souhaite laisser sa place
à benjamin combien de temps pour
destituer faire le tour jean michel est
ce que vous êtes capable à boussac de
vous sacrifier pour benjamin plutôt
crever merci thierry est ce que vous
êtes capable de vous sacrifier pour
benjamin dans d'autres circonstances oui
mais là pas du tout ouais vraiment envie
de partir oui maxime âgé déjà sacrifié
mon numéro de téléphone ce soir moi je
suis prêt évidemment mais évidemment je
veux aller en tunisie
bon alors tu dis non donc tu dis non non
il ya la moc tard non segal vu la fin à
notre fiche tandis qu'on partira à 10 et
pas un de plus gilles sincèrement oui
non francesca je suis venu pour partir
donc non
j'ai pas envie quoi isabelle moi c'est
con parce que j'ai justement envie de
partir avec lui le vraiment une plage
lui laisse la mienne mais ça me ferait
chier parce qu'il fait beau mais non
mais non
sylvain sibomana cela lui laisse mais
c'est oui ou c'est non
ce que n'ont pas immédiatement à poil
c'est incroyable pas la peine moi
en bref je pensais pas faire ça un jour
parce que j'ai jamais rien donné à
quelqu'un non mais et parce que la
tunisie mon pays de coeur et j'ai été
nommé par l'ambassadeur mais il se
trouve que j'aurais fait pour personne
d'autre
mais je vais être sincère de seconde
celui qui m'a tendu la main
comment tu dans la rue avec une valise
dans ma voiture et je ne savais pas où
dormir
ceux qui devaient les trois semaines qui
m'a prêté ses voitures ses vacances son
argent ces femmes
non non pas ces femmes on s'est
engueulés parfois ensuite mais il ya des
1000 défaut mais le coeur est aussi gros
que cet homme que son talent pour le
coup et c'est peut-être la première fois
que je vais pouvoir lui rendre ce qu'il
m'avait donné ce jour là autrement que
par un merci
donc je te laisse partir cette voie
[Applaudissements]